haber on s'est fait depuis bien
longtemps
à l'arrivée au début de l'après-midi de
la voiture de monsieur deux camps quelle
que soit la saison
quel que soit le temps c'est ainsi cela
fait comme partie des moeurs du village
on ne s'étonne pas davantage de voir
quelques instants plus tard monsieur
françois decaux a poussé la porte tout à
fait où il rampe pour quelques rares
comment
l'entente où les géniales mais même
ponctuellement et je n'ai jamais plus de
vacances
comment s'est passée la première fois je
me suis demandé si tu l'as fait voler
pensionnat qu'adopter tout de suite un
signal aux pluies sont venus rappeler
fois bientôt le jour d'hui ses
découvertes et des amis venez souvent
régulièrement toutes les quatre semaines
comment je voulais coupe aux routes
habituelles rude comme d'habitude chez
cegos sur les côtés mais depuis très
longtemps je fais le littéraire parce
que m6
anne sonnet y avait pas assez nombreux
pour occuper un pas faire toute la
semaine pourquoi le golfeur une ancienne
habitude il venait au village le ou au
paf et cafés étant fermés momentanément
était venu donc j'ai chez moi pour
pousser clients venaient se faire couper
à la maison comme ils étaient habitués
le faire lui coûter la vie
dans la cuisine c'est bien plus
sympathique
disons qu'on est entre amis toutefois
chômeurs c'est sans gêne pour venir
régulièrement la cathine toutes les
quatre semaines parce que ça vaut pas le
coup d'y placer un peu bien dit non
c'est gentil ça fait longtemps que je
viens je sais plus tôt entre amis que je
viens c'est pas pour eux eh bien vous
dire combien de clients
comment vous venez pour que mon salut
pour ça les paniers tout ça n'est pas
dupe on ne peut pas tellement dit le
nouveau client se fichant des morts
certes les justes monsieur pour mieux
nous n'est pas toujours là n'est pas
toujours là et puis par pure team
renault il parvient à messi
ce n'est pas encore la fin c'est pas
s'il fallait compter là dessus pour
vivre je vous assure que ça hein
avec l'effet de voitures tout ça mais
c'est plutôt par an entre amis
maintenant on va traquer
comme des rues morillon et au mois c'est
un rite tous les vendredis c'est il ya
des gens qui viennent parce que le
coiffeur bien même s'ils n'ont pas
besoin de se faire couper les cheveux
ils viennent ils viennent pas chez le
coiffeur que monde ils viennent au
coiffeur restons français n'est ce pas
si c'est vraiment épatant des métiers
qui se perdre ça je veux pas dire par là
que le métier de coiffeur race perdre
non il restera toujours le métier de
coiffeur mais comme il est pratiqué ici
on la verra bientôt plus alors lui coupé
assez court bien consommer
[Musique]
je
en quarante ans de tournée ce ne sont
pas les anecdotes qui mentent doctoraux
quitté ans qui était ministre de
l'agriculture et puis son genre peut
l'amener prendre le temps à dijon le
chauffeur retourner à bouilly qui lavait
la voiture une belle peur de ce moment
là c'est en 1934 peut-être quelque chose
comme ça tant de 5,35 parle alors d'une
division soit on va faire la fête à
massilly on va à la fin à la fête à
masquer une part si tu veux on y va on
ouvre la partie
tout s'est bien passé pour harry on
arrive à bercy il était petit 8 heures
du soir la fête était encore pas
commencé il m'a dit vas tu ne sais pas
on va aller jusqu'à celui de saulieu
c'est pas loin bon on arrive à saulieu
on a enfin le fait naturellement
j'avais 20 ans ce moment là est lui vers
une heure du matin est venu mais mon
chauffeur n'avait abouti coup alors sur
la route je disais va donc passer vite
j'en donne va non pas ceux qui sapent
légende on va donc passer vitaux tu sais
moi quand je suis un bout de bois aux le
tient bien
mais arrivés dans un virage nous v'la
106 où nous lançons le sud-soudan
phocéen en bande ou la jolie l'import
affichent eu ben j'ai dit quatre
personnes deux hommes de se faire couper
les cheveux
qu'est ce qui va me sony alors à ce
moment là il me donne est simple un
pourboire
alors quand j'ai eu fini puis coupez les
chewing on n'a pas parlé bien du tout
quand j'ai eu fini de lui couper les
cheveux qu'il est venu payer et bindi
les seins fermes pour boire que je te
donnais dans le temps ça cela poserait
pas les ma voiture
dis moi les mains
[Musique]